rousseau yves derai notre série spéciale
élections régionales continuent on
s'arrête ce soir dans le grand est où le
président sortant est l'ère jean rottner
est reparti en campagne il est en tête
dans les sondages et c'est assez rare
pour être signalé il est devant le
rassemblement national il y aussi une
ministre dans la course les enjeux et la
campagne sur le terrain c'est avec
marion vigreux et louis duminil à
suspense et surtout effectivement il
vient des présidents de région qui est
le plus monté au créneau pendant la
crise qu'ovide critiquant vivement
l'action gouvernementale le candidat et
l'ère jean rottner ici en déplacement
dans les ardennes pour parler transport
est un fervent défenseur de la
décentralisation qu'il estime
aujourd'hui incarné vous savez nous
avons été fortement touché par la crise
et par la pandémie
l'an dernier il tient dès les premiers
jours dès mi mars nous sommes mis au
travail pour adopter notre propre plan
de relance avec les acteurs économiques
j'attends qu'une décentralisation qui
viendrait de paris je n'y crois plus par
contre bien le travail en commun avec
les départements avec les
intercommunalités et très souvent avec
les préférant région donne des résultats
absolument exceptionnelle nous en avons
apporté la preuve ici dans la région
conséquence celui qui a choisi de se
passer de nadine morano prévient sa
liste est faite et il n'y aura pas
d'alliance au second tour avec celle
soutenue par la république en marche n'y
aura pas de fusion entre le premier et
le deuxième tour je partirai avec la
même équipe
ça joue en faveur de la carte et et de
la position ça m'a fait plaisir vous
rencontrer
ans et a nommé 21 25 la majorité
présidentielle est ici incarné par
brigitte klinkert ministre délégué à
l'insertion dans le gouvernement castex
elle fait de la proximité l'un de ses
thèmes de campagne dans une région très
vaste qu'elle souhaite réorganiser
depuis que je suis sur matin dans l'aube
eh bien je rencontre des maires je
rencontre des chefs d'entreprise qui me
disent avoir zéro contact avec la région
et quand ils en ont et nous disent que
elle est trop éloignée et que les
dossiers sont beaucoup trop complexe et
souvent il repense aux aides de la
région
donc ma priorité c'est la sortie de
crise m dans la proximité
elle se présente comme une candidate du
rassemblement du centre et de la droite
et ne se ferme a aucune alliance au soir
du premier tour
je suis parti dans cette campagne pour
être en tête et ensuite moi je suis
connue en commettant une femme de
consensus une une femme de dialogue et
le moment venu je prendrai mes
responsabilités je crois que vous avez
aujourd'hui une nouvelle concurrence qui
arrive à epernay le candidat du
rassemblement national laurent
jacobellis rencontre le syndicat des
vignerons
l'occasion de présenter son programme
lui qui souhaite aussi le retour aux
trois régions d'origine alsace lorraine
et champagne ardenne
on se retrouve aujourd'hui avec une
vraie perte d'identité les alsaciens
sont malheureux de ce grand test en
champagne ardenne on est malheureux
parce que depuis strasbourg
eh bien on peut pas comprendre les
réalités locales côté alliance pas de
dialogue en vue avec florian philippot
des patriotes mais en revanche des mains
se tendent vers la droite ayant ouvert
très largement cette liste à des gens
qui viennent de divers droite comme le
sénateur jean louis masson qui est sans
étiquette par exemple des gens qui
viennent de la société civile tous ceux
qui peuvent se reconnaître dans ce
programme
travaillons ensemble il n'y a pas
d'exclusive voilà il se trouve qu'ici
c'est vrai que je vois là j'ai des
points communs avec naïvement je crois
qu'elle a choisi d'être fidèle à son
parti ce qui nous empêchera pas si
demain les électeurs nous font confiance
de travailler ensemble en tout cas moi
je ferai appel à son expertise et son
expérience
de l'autre côté de l'échiquier politique
à gauche on est divisé l'ancien ministre
aurélie filippetti et chef de file de la
paix l'inédit soutenu par les insoumis
les radicaux de gauche et génération
mais pas par le ps qui se range derrière
la candidate europe ecologie les verts
eliane romani moi pour ma part j'ai
tendu la main jusqu'au bout bien sûr que
c'est dommage pour autant ce
rassemblement qui y est celui de la de
l'elysée comme islamiste il est
suffisamment vaste pour ouvrir un espoir
je pense pour beaucoup de d'habitantes
et habitante grant est une candidate qui
veut porter un élan écologique sur ce
territoire rural et industriel c'est
intéressant au contraire de voir que là
on est dans une industrie dans une scop
de voir comment les entreprises amorce
la transition écologique et au wap aux
frontières de cette région
les écologistes sont arrivés au pouvoir
ici en allemagne avec ce moment là où
des sites et donc j'imagine tout à fait
moi que ce grand test pourrait avoir
contredit dans tout collège quant aux
tendances à quinze jours du premier tour
le président sortant est le candidat du
r'n font la course en tête dans les
sondages est avec nous pour ce match des
idées ce soir sandrine rousseau
bienvenue vous êtes maîtresse de
conférences en économie candidate
déclarée à la primaire europe
ecologie-les verts pour la
présidentielle et vice présidente de
l'université de lille face à vous ils
devraient bienvenue si vous êtes
journaliste politique et rédacteur en
chef de forbes france on est à moins de
15 jours des régionales on voit que le
rassemblement national est décidément un
rival assez sérieux pour tous les
sortants sandrine rousseau comment vous
le voyez ce scrutin est ce que vous
dites que finalement ça risque d'être un
tremplin pour le rassemblement national
ou pas il faut tout faire pour que ça ne
soit pas un mais elle a de fait les
idées on sent bien que les idées de
l'extrême droite progresse en france et
qu'il nous faut au contraire lever un
espoir créer quelque chose à gauche pour
qu'il y ait une forme de contre balance
qui ce qui s'organise dans le pays après
je pense que là on est à une espèce de
moment de vérité c'est à ce que les
électeurs iront se lever pour un projet
comme on l'a vu là dans le grand test
qui soit un projet d'union un projet
original radical et j'espère qu'ils
iront et qu'elles devront se lever et
vraiment je les appelle à léo on voit
parce que enfin les athées payet que la
participation oui la clé c'est la
participation et puis surtout on ne peut
pas faire comme si c'était anodin ce qui
était en train de se passer alors je
sais qu'on le dit depuis maintenant des
années mais là on est quand même à ce
moment de bascule où quelque part il ya
une responsabilité collectives mais
aussi individuelles et donc voilà il ya
on a besoin d'une démocratie en france
qui porte un espoir qui porte cette
espèce d'esprit qui a marqué la france
depuis des siècles qui est l'esprit
d'avant garde l'esprit éclairé et là en
l'occurrence on se tourne vers
l'obscurité alors que la lumière est à
côté vous avez employé le mot anodin
bruno le maire ce week-end sur europe 1
il nous dit le front national ce n'est
pas grand chose ce n'est pas un grand
parti ce n'est pas de grandes
personnalités ce n'est pas un grand
projet pour le pays
ce à quoi a répondu d'ailleurs marine le
pen très vite quelques minutes plus tard
sur rtl il devrait peut-être
considère-t-il aussi que les français
sont de petites gens nous verrons les
résultats de la république en marche à
l'issue du premier tour des élections
régionales
je crois que c'était une déclaration
politique assez maladroite de bruno le
maire parce que
on voit aujourd'hui c'est sans doute
peut-être le premier parti de france
donc
pas grand chose mais enfin ça compte
dans le sur l'échiquier politique
malheureusement moi quand j'écoute
madame
avec cette forte prise de conscience que
vous voulez que les français prennent
au monde ce scrutin j'espère aussi que
les partis politiques auront une prise
de conscience parce que ce sera un
succès pour le front national est un
tremplin
si en face ça tangue c'est à dire qu'à
un moment donné il va falloir se poser
la question quand même de savoir si oui
ou non on veut faire barrage au
rassemblement national et donc parfois
retirer des candidats réfléchir à des
faire fusionner des listes faire en
sorte que y est ce fameux front
républicain on n'a pas trouvé beaucoup
mieux pour l'instant c'est peut-être pas
idéal
on connaît les difficultés que ça peut
poser parce que du coup pas ça s'adonne
au saxo mais mes yeux j'avais
malheureusement si c'est le seul choix
pour faire en sorte que d'être ces
grandes régions ne tombe pas dans
l'escarcelle durant ce moment un schéma
mais j'espère que ça s'organise rats
entre deux tours le front républicain ça
fonctionne dès lors que les partis qui
bénéficient de ce front républicain
respecte derrière ce qui a été fait au
moment de l'élection et le désistement
d'une partie de la démocratie ça n'a pas
été le cas en eau de france avec xavier
bertrand qui n'a jamais jamais travaillé
avec les personnes qui se sont désistés
en sa faveur
jamais il n'a eu un projet écologistes
et de gauche jamais jamais à un moment
donné c'est votre responsabilité aussi
que d'entendre ce pour quoi nous nous
sommes désisté et enfin des autres mais
en tout cas ailleurs responsable mais la
responsabilité en l'occurrence de xavier
bertrand ou la responsabilité en paca de
la même manière et donc là on ne peut
pas être dupe systématiquement du fait
que c'est au nom d'un rapport de force
on doive se désister sent que derrière
les personnes qui sont élus à la faveur
de ce rapport de force ne prennent pas
en compte la dimension qui leur a permis
d'être élu et en l'occurrence l'écologie
et sociale et donc faire avoir quand
même que ça participe de la montée du rn
aussi parce que la question qui vient
derrière le vote rassemblement national
est une question de respect des
personnes de considération de ce qu ils
sont où ils sont et
manière dont ils vivent des difficultés
dans lesquelles ils vivent et que là on
a l'impression que au moment des
élections tout le monde à de grands mots
et que dès le lendemain tout est oublié
tout allons vous parler de l'obscurité
de lumière et là tout d'un coup on a
l'impression qu'il ya plus que
l'obscurité quoi vous fait pas vraiment
de différence en fait entre le xavier
bertrand et leur assemblée nationale
parce que j'en faisais nous nous sommes
désolés la description mais quelle est
la déception mais je crois qu'à un
moment donné c'est triste à dire mais
quand on est face à des choix aussi
grave pour le pays aussi important si on
considère que ce sont des choix gras
avait des moments historiques pour le
pays que des régions aussi importante
bascule
hors assemblée nationale à quelques mois
de la présidentielle ça veut dire que là
on trace une route très dangereuse vers
peut-être l'accession au pouvoir je
termine juste l'accession au pouvoir du
front national à l'éducation nationale
j'arrive pas toujours un sur le le bon
nom parce que je me battrai tant que ça
la différence et donc ça veut dire que
de temps en temps malheureusement c'est
comme ça en démocratie au second tour il
faut faire il faut choisir entre
guillemets le moins pire c'est comme ça
même et de toutes mes forces à ce que le
rassemblement national ne gagne pas de
région ni de départements ce que je veux
dire aussi c'est que dans des situations
exceptionnelles il faut des hommes et
des femmes politiques exceptionnelles et
qu'en l'occurrence les dernières
élections régionales ne nous en ont pas
montré et que sa porte ça participe de
la responsabilité de la montée
progressive du rassemblement national
loin elle est parlant du fait
du jour c'est cette scène incroyable
dans la drôme le président de la
république giflé lors de son déplacement
qui était consacrée aux restaurateurs
alors emmanuel macron a réagi depuis
auprès de nos confrères du dauphiné il
dénonce des faits isolés d'individus
ultraviolents avalanche de réactions
évidemment depuis l'incident je vous
cite juste le tweet de gérard larcher
tout à l'heure je vais exprimer tout mon
soutient emmanuel macron victime d'une
agression intolérable et inacceptable
qui appelle à une mobilisation totale de
la république face à la violence qui se
développe dans notre pays fin de
citation écoutons maintenant la réaction
de jean castex dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée tout à l'heure la démocratie
et vous en est l'illustration c'est le
sait le débat c'est le dialogue c'est la
confrontation d'idées c'est l'expression
de désaccord légitime
bien entendu mais ça ne peut en aucun
cas être la violence l'agression verbale
et encore moins l'agression physique
j'en appelle à un sursaut républicain
nous sommes tous concernés
il en va des fondements de notre
démocratie est toute la question est de
savoir ce qu'on met aussi derrière le
sursaut républicain sandrine rousseau
j'imagine que vous condamnez évidemment
ce qui s'est passé mais qu'est ce que ça
dit pour vous du climat politique
ça dit plusieurs choses ça dit déjà que
on est dans une
réelle violence du débat politique
sadique aussi et on ne respecte plus la
démocratie représentative et certaines
fonctions de cette démocratie
représentative comme étant quelque chose
qui ne doit pas être entaché est touché
voilà une fois que les élections sont
passées ça c'est grave en cela c'est
quand même un sujet très inquiétant et
puis ça dit aussi je pense à quel point
emmanuel macron par cette espèce de
personnification à outrance du pouvoir
personnifie aussi les critiques et les
la révolte qui vit qui peut y avoir dans
la société
et là c'est pour ça que moi j'en appelle
à une réforme de la constitution pour
dire on est on est arrivé au bout de
cette vème république
manifestement le fait que le pouvoir
soit incarnée par un seul par une seule
personne de manière très autoritaire qui
décide dans des conseils de guerre et
dans les conditions les plus obscurs je
crois que la gym trop présidentielle
quoi régime trop présidentielle régime
trop personnel et régime qui ne répond
plus à rien et moi j'ai vraiment
l'impression que j'ai relu c'est ce
week-end les cahiers des états généraux
de l'artois voilà je suis tombé sur le
livre qui était dans ma bibliothèque
mais que j'avais laissé de côté et j'ai
été très impressionné par les mots qui
ont été utilisés à l'époque et qui
finalement 10 un peu de notre situation
actuelle qui est de dire mais là on ne
reconnaît plus l'autorité c'était l'euro
à l'époque mais là on reconnaît plus
l'autorité du président de la république
je pense que c'est un climat
d'insurrection quand même il faut quoi
il enfin si c'est le peuple c'est bon si
c'est l'armée c'est moins bon donc il va
falloir quand même quand on trouve les
moyens d'une révolte douce et d'une
révolution douce qui permettent de
remettre des personnes qui incarnent la
société au poste à responsabilités par
les mots et pas par la violence il
devrait donc je suis un peu choqué par
ce que je viens longtemps très parce que
même de jean luc mélenchon à marine le
pen tout le monde a tenu des propos
extrêmement responsable dans un contexte
où le président république qui incarne
tous les français qui représentent tous
les français a été agressée est donc
fort heureusement les gens qui sont en
responsabilité dans les partis mêmes
extrémistes montré une solidarité là
j'entends quelqu'un ici et non
desservies daris non pas du tout
fermement non non je condamne fermement
ce faux je condamne fermement toute
année ce que j'ai entendu là dans votre
intervention c'est un peu il ne l'a pas
volé c'est à dire que i là bas si vous
venez de dire qu' il a conduit le pays
d'une manière extrêmement autoritaire
dans le sucre est un conseil de guerre
il prend ses décisions comme cela et
donc on arrive au bout d'un système et
donc ce geste d'une certaine manière
découle d'une certaine logique
donc on vous avez même attribué à ce
geste quasiment la nécessité de passer à
la 6ème république
ce serait un geste extrêmement
victorieux de ce cette espèce de
d'hurluberlus enfin peu qui m'a l'air
j'ai commencé à lire sur lui qui
visiblement se déguise en tenue
médiévale en forêt qui fait des arts
martiaux qui datent de 1500 ans ou
et quelque chose comme ça donc
malheureusement on a déjà
justin depuis dans les placer dans le
mandat jacques chirac on a même envisagé
de l'assassiner puisque maxime devenu
une arme à feu s'étaient pas eu une
gifle à peine esquissés parce que manuel
m'apprend eu un bon réflexe des esquives
pour ne pas la subir et puis les
services d'intervention sont très vite
intervenus donc franchement c'est un
geste qu'il ne faut certainement pas
laisser passer
je pense que emmanuel matheron président
république quand il va comme cela à la
rencontre des français en bras de
chemise
il y retourner après de retourner après
et c'est bien c'est comme parfois quand
on tombe de cheval il faut remonter tout
de suite sur le cheval pour ne pas être
victime traumatisée
donc je trouve ça plutôt bien qu'il ait
continué montrer aussi la continuité
républicaine à travers le fait de
continuer de poursuivre le programme qui
qui qui était prévu mais néanmoins il
est sans doute quand même il a sans
doute été un peu choqué par ce part cela
parce que on ne peut pas être jeté on ne
peut pas ne pas imaginer aussi que si ce
garçon avait eu l'âme dans la main ou
quelque chose comme ça le geste aurait
pu être encore plus dramatique
une petite lamerat de rasoir ça veut
dire ça se paie cash très facilement
donc donc je veux pas imaginer ce qui
aurait pu se passer mais comment lui
dans sa pole n'a pas pu l'imaginer
voilà rien au sort non je voudrais juste
dire qu'un je condamne et je condamne
sans aucune espèce d'ambiguïté
le geste mais en vraiment aucune espèce
d'ambiguïté et je condamne fortement
tout à toute agression au président de
la république jeudi jusque là on est
dans un moment politique qui est un
moment particulier de violence de
partout qui sans doute aussi un peu une
conséquence des crises que l'on connaît
et que l'on traverse et qu'il faut
entendre le
la violence sociale qui lie à axel dos
quand emmanuel macron 10 et dénonce je
cite des faits isolés d'individus
ultraviolents vous pensez qu'il minimise
pas ça je peux faire ça mais difficile
de dire dans la mesure où j'ai pas les
rapports king auxquels il a accès mais
en tous les cas je pense qu'il ya là un
geste un saint un symbole que l'on doit
est condamné et ne pas minimiser
complètement
un dernier mot là dessus j'aimerais bien
quand même qu'on ait des résultats d
entre eux ddd de l'enquète il ya il ya
une enquête
ces gens sont en garde à vue ils vont ne
s'est pas vraiment qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'ils vont engagement politique
claire ils nous ont quand même à les
prononcer ils ont prononcé quand même un
slogan de l'action française le fameux
mon jouet saint denis qui est un un cri
de guerre un peu royalistes donc tout ça
n'est pas neutre on est dans un contexte
quand même peut-être où il y a une sorte
de je suis pas on dirait on dirait des
gens qui appartiennent à une sorte de
milice d'extrême droite royalistes qui
ont tenté ce coup de force donc en jeu
peut-être qu'on va réussir à déterminer
très exactement d'où est partie cette
opération ce coup parce que ça avait
l'air un peu prévu sont plusieurs ils
savaient ce qu'ils avaient à dire
on voit que dans la manière dont ça a
été fait il ya quand même un certain
savoir-faire aussi chez cet homme qui
est donc visiblement féru d'arts
martiaux est les autres thèmes le
système de départage
r on en parlait en début d'émission avec
quentin calme mais ils continuent d'être
affiné ce système surtout au sénat sous
la houlette d'ailleurs de gérard larcher
un déjeuner avait lieu ce midi avec les
têtes pensantes du projet et si eric
zemmour il participait questions ou
proposition formulée par le député lr
julien aubert dans un entretien à
l'express pourquoi ne participerait t'il
pas un mécanisme de départage des
républicains il a toute sa place
il n'est pas aux arènes et peut attirer
une partie de l'électorat
lr voilà les propos de juillet aubert
avant de vous demander votre avis on va
prendre celui d'étienne blanc dont soir
vous êtes sénateur l ère du rhône
bienvenue à vous dans ce match des idées
eric zemmour qui participerait à la
primaire de la droite qu'en pensez vous
les rires aujourd'hui sont dans une
situation compliquée une grande partie
de leurs électeurs ne voteront pas pour
la liste elle est notamment dans la
région paca est donc la question qui se
pose c'est de savoir comment ces
électeurs qui viennent de l'ancien rpr
ou de l'ancienne udf peuvent revenir à
l'occasion d'une élection présidentielle
pour voter pour le candidat qui sera
présenté avec le soutien des
républicains
et dans ce cadre là il faut laisser le
choix le choix le plus large possible
donc la proposition qui a été faite par
julien aubert groupe ares est frappé au
coin du bon sens parce que nous avons un
grand nombre d'électeurs qui considère
qu'aujourd'hui
eric zemmour représente une part de la
droite et que ceux de droite là et si il
n'ya pas sims il n'y a pas un ges et
bien à partir de ce moment là elle ne
veut plus pour nous et on est sûr au
second tour d'une élection résidentielle
de ne pas être présent voilà toute
l'équation et je crois que jean louis
julie aubert pardon à raison tient cette
proposition alors elle est innovante
elle va susciter beaucoup de
commentaires et je crois qu'il a eu
raison de la faire etienne blanc vous
savez d'ailleurs si les cadres du parti
le lui ont proposé à eric zemmour ou pas
non je crois pour l'instant rien n'a été
proposé c'est une proposition qui a été
faite par julien baer
mais je pense que cette proposition
mérite intérêt et et vous pensez qu'il
aurait des chances d'être désignée vous
qui connaissez quand même les militants
du parti et l'air je ne sais pas ce que
je constate aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de militants d'adhérents et
l'air d'élus l'air qui se reconnaissent
dans le discours des rites d'eric
zemmour sur par exemple la défense d'un
certain nombre de valeurs sûres par
exemple elle est la défense sur des
sujets qui touchent à l'histoire de
france à ses traditions et qui veulent
que ce sera de vienne au coeur du débat
politique
donc cet électeur alain il se reconnaît
oui chez eric zemmour à pâtir de ce long
mois quelles seront les votes
on peut pas en président et qui seront
les candidats on peut pas en présager
c'est quelqu'un et le problème est
aujourd'hui déjà y avait quatre ans
annoncé qu'il était candidat et mais
xavier bertrand n'est plus membre de la
république un donc l'élection il doit
être ouverte de ce fait là et qu'elle
soit ouverte à eric zemmour
je ne crois pas qu'ils aient pas membre
du front national et qui ne l'a jamais
été
je pense que ce n'est pas une mauvaise
chose dans la mesure où une grande
partie de nos électeurs se reconnaissent
dans ses idées rester avec nos etienne
blanc on va continuer d'en parler
évidemment en plateau et je vous
laisserai intervenir une nouvelle fois
sans rides rousseau 7
le fait que le parti allait un parti
historique le parti de la droite puisse
envisager une telle proposition ça vous
choque ça vous heurte ou pas du tout je
suis pas des républicains mais oui c'est
choquant oui c'est heurtant quelle
valeur porte eric zemmour la halle
valeurs d'égalité femmes-hommes les
valeurs de lutte contre le racisme et
d'égalité des personnes et que porte
eric zemmour qu'est-ce qu'il porte dans
la violence du débat politique dont on
vient de parler dont on vient de
s'émouvoir
qu'est-ce qu'il porte comme
responsabilité dans la violence de ceux
de de ce débat politique et on voudrait
le faire passer pour par une primaires
des présidentielles
je pense que les républicains ne
s'honorerait pas du tout de cette de
cette décision
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui a été
condamné et qui a été condamné sur une
vision politique et il n'a pas été
condamné par erreur ou par quelque chose
qui n'a rien à voir avec la politique il
a été condamné sur sa ligne politique
parce qu'elles ne respectaient pas la
république et c'est ça qu'on veut
qu'on veut porter comme candidat à la
présidentielle eh bien tous les cas moi
je m' affronterait a sagement
affronterait alors au projet politique
qui est derrière la candidature d'eric
zemmour yves derai je pense que c'est un
gros pièges que tend la julien aubert je
ne peux pas imaginer autre chose que
cela
parce que très sincèrement et eric
zemmour dans une primaire et l'air dont
on ne connaît même pas les modalités
pour l'instant c'était un jeudi une
primaire ce sera peut-être pas tout à
fait une primaire monsieur leonetti va
superviser ce dispositif le départage
puis après comment ça va se faire dans
une fusée j'attends donc pas chaque
tasse évident c'est pour eric zemmour
qui se présenteraient en franc-tireur
essai et s'ils se présentent ce sera
comme cela qui se présentera parce que
dans sa vision à lui une présidentielle
c'est une rencontre entre un homme et le
peuple et il est pas favorable aux
primaires
donc il doit pas aller dans un système
qui dénoncent par ailleurs depuis qu'il
est contre les primaires donc tu vas me
sens sans doute pas à tomber là dedans
c'est que ça pour se débarrasser de eric
zemmour ça qu il rentre dans une
primaire il est battu à la primaire
parce qu'il serait battu à la primaire
et on se débarrasse d'un avec zemmour
qui ré la revanche piquer quelques
points
en candidat de droite éventuellement un
candidat est reine et favoriserait sans
doute la candidature des milieux macro
floch bien stratégie c'est pour moi
c'est pure stratégie parce que je vous
dis encore une fois eric zemmour il
n'est pas question qu'ils aient envie
d'aller dans ce système dans ce
dispositif là et de surcroît il a accusé
eric zemmour c'est quelqu'un que je
connais depuis longtemps
tout ce que dit madame rousseau est tout
à fait juste sur le fond mais dans la
forme c'est quelqu'un qui est très à
l'aise dans son petit monde des médias à
la table de ceux des chroniqueurs où il
connaît des sujets à l'avance et oui le
répond à des choses sur lesquelles il a
planché parce qu il est bosseur donc en
général il travaille trés c'est pas
pareil qu'un mystique c'est pas pareil
cas les jeux suire marché a serré des
mains parce que d'accès mûri et quand
ils arrivent face à une foule il n'est
pas rassuré c'est pas quelqu'un qui est
à l'aise là dedans vous savez c'est je
vais prendre une image mais c'est un peu
comme quand on est séduit par le jeu ou
du club med et qu'on le ramène à paris
et que sa voix refus quoi eric zemmour
vous la mettez ensuite quand vous
plonger dans l'huile bouillante d'une
campagne présidentielle et ça va pas
marcher
on a vu une fois ou deux prendre la
parole à une tribune à un pupitre je
crois que c'était même lors quand même
d'un meeting organisé par marion
maréchal
il me semble bien donc toute sa place
chez à l'air ça se discute aussi ça
comme un là on est sur la ligne très
pelti loin je m'étonne un peu qu'ils
tiennent blancs disent ils avaient
confirme cela mais il était très mal à
l'aise il est incapable de parler en
public devant une salle de 2000
personnes donc franchement s'il serait
évidemment battue et hop on dégage eric
zemmour de la piste alors après
évidemment etienne blanc je vous laisse
répondre je pense qu'il faut pas jouer
avec le feu et qu'à force de jouer avec
le feu il est quand même possible que
les choses s'enflamme sens et que là en
l'occurrence les républicains se
déshonorerait vraiment chrétienne dans
votre lit etienne blanc je sais pas si
vous m'entendez encore pardon je vous
entendrez un nouveau seuil et non je ne
pense pas que ce soit une question de
deux légionnaires et aujourd'hui quand
on regarde les sondages et on s'aperçoit
que
républicains sont en passe de ne pas
être sélectionné pour le second tour
d'une élection présidentielle
et s'ils ne le sont pas c'est parce que
leurs électeurs en grand nombre les ont
abandonnées en raison du fait que sur un
certain nombre de sujets ne s'exprimait
plus il nous est plus sous une espèce de
chape de plomb sous une bien pensants
s'il nous est plus s'exprimer sur 100
mesures
en tout cas c'est ce qu'ils disent est
là la venue d'eric zemmour dans une
primaire et je pense qu'en seul julien
aubert a raison elle permet à ses
électeurs de s'exprimer et de retrouver
les voix de la raison pour participer à
une élection présidentielle dans
laquelle je le redis aujourd'hui
l est républicain son utilisation
extrêmement forme je regarde ce qui
se passe dans les sondages pour les
élections régionales
les républicains sont en passe de ne pas
être sélectionné dans un certain nombre
de régions où historiquement il est
extrêmement puissant pas les gagner
pardon dans un certain nombre de régions
il était extrêmement puissant c'est
évidemment le cas de la région paca
donc la démarche qui est fait elle me
paraît très très pertinente
il devrait s'en aller sur cette ligne et
maurienne à dire ils ont tout ce qu'il
faut chaleur ils ont laurent wauquiez
qu'il y ait candidat qu à peu près sur
la même ligne julien aubert lui même qui
évoque cette idée aura tout à fait
candidater
sheller pourquoi pas je ne sais pas moi
il haïssait les gens m'ont plein et ce
fameux guillaume pelletier qui vient de
faire cette sortie qui pourrait tout à
fait incarner aussi cette voie là et
dire des choses que monsieur blanc
aimerait qu'on dise dans cette campagne
dont il ya pas besoin d'aller chercher
eric zemmour à l'extérieur parce que
c'est un personnage médiatique ça me
semble vraiment plus tôt une manoeuvre
politique
une sincère envie de voir eric zemmour
représenter des couleurs de l air à
l'élection présidentielle henri dans son
appui à un moment donné mieux vaut
perdre avec honneur que gagner avec des
honneurs parfois on a même et la défaite
et le déshonneur et que là c'est quand
même la pente vers laquelle font des
républicains etienne blanc d'ailleurs
vous ne craignez pas que le parti ait
l'air puis samples osé si toutefois eric
zemmour d'ailleurs été désigné ou si
d'ailleurs juste il es t il participer à
cette primaire et je pense qu'il faut
donner la parole aux militants et ce dès
ce qui porte les couleurs des
républicains puis ensuite ils font le
choix mais exclure cette opportunité je
pense que c'est une énorme erreur
c'est il faut faire un constat
aujourd'hui nos électeurs nous demande
un discours plus faire le discours plus
clair et se reconnaissent pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux dans le
d'histoire c'est vrai que ces news c'est
un outil médiatique extrêmement
puissants ce que je constate aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il est en train entre
guillemets et de gagner des parts de
marché en tout cas deux noms très
important de nos électeurs se
reconnaissent sur ce média alors
pourquoi se priver de ce débat pourquoi
se priver de ce débat absolue est seul
on ressent de plus en plus quand on
entend les militants les électeurs aient
l'air et ils veulent une franchise et
ils veulent être libres ils veulent
s'exprimer et ils veulent parler de
sujets sur lesquels pendant des années
on leur a interdit de s'exprimer
oui parler de la france parlait de
conservatisme c'est pas une erreur et
quand on prive les électeurs de cela
bien sûr là ils vont vers d'autres
formations politiques et notamment vers
le rassemblement national
je pense que cette
un très très bon outil pour à nouveau
remettre les l air au coeur du débat
politique et message est clair merci
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce match des idées ne me regardez pas
comme ça oui c'est déjà fini on sait que
c'était intéressant tout cas c'est la
fin on se retrouve demain à 18 heures et
à 22 heures 30 demain également 7h30
bonjour chez vous et oriane mancini
recevra notamment sébastien lecornu
ministre d outre-mer excellente soirée
sur public sénat